if i was gonna look up one problem cop
was a prime example of what's gone wrong
here in baltimore where would i start
because we wanna yeah we wanna run a
little hypothetical by you
said we're on an investigation we're
fine big time drug dealer real [ __ ]
monster right
[Music]
we uh you know we get win on where he's
keeping his cash
and we actually come upon that cash
it's right there in front of us we just
you know we take it
what would you think about that
[Applause]
everything changed when they came up
with that expression the war on drugs
with the war comes police militarization
the complete gutting of the fourth
amendment
they put me in a unit made up of a bunch
of the biggest crooks in the whole
goddamn department there's all this
money to be made and i'm somehow
supposed to be playing about a book with
these [ __ ]
so these cops caught lying
and with their abusive behavior remained
on the street they did
if it is the feds were honest the case
could go on for you what case
single papo escobar is the police
in a war you need warriors
you have enemies in a war civilians get
hurt and nobody does anything in a war
you count the bodies
and then you call them victories
aren't you angry
[Music]
[Applause]
you